if you're a fan of Bayonetta and of
course you are you'll be happy to know
the bayonetta 2 is being re-released as
a standalone game for half the price I'm
Kate and this is your gamespot news
update Bayonetta 2 is being re-released
on Wii U this time as a standalone game
nintendo of america announced on
thursday the game will be available for
thirty dollars beginning on februari the
19th it's already available on its own
on Nintendo's a shop for fifty dollars
however the only physical version
released in october 2014 came packaged
with a copy of the first Bayonetta which
was previously an xbox 360 and ps3 only
game the physical bundle has since
become difficult to find without
resorting to places like eBay where it
routinely sells for more than the
original retail price this is also ahead
of Bayonetta inclusion in smash bros
next month and a cheeky amiibo of the
leggy lass do you love Bayonetta of
course you do let me know in the
comments how much you love Bayonetta or
come and find me on Twitter I'm at how
not to draw thanks for watching and for
all your gaming and entertainment
updates keep it gamespot
you